communication with my other children  meaning the children that live with kate  is very difficult because i have been  alienated from those children i think it  was a poor parenting decision will you  try to reach out to them now i've  already texted them before but i've  never got a response she became one of  the most recognizable people in this  country she also became one of the hated  she's the karen she is the karen she's  the karen meme like hello do you ever  wish these two could have gotten the law  always yeah it would be nice you know  stand in a room with them and not  think that they hate each other but they  still  both love me so it's fine